(upbeat music)
- Hi everyone, Sal Khan here.
From finding novel cures for
a seemingly incurable disease
to diagnosing what's going on with someone
if you're a physician or a nurse,
you can imagine there is
incredible creativity in biology.
And don't take my word for it.
You're now going to
meet some of my friends
who can tell you more
about that connection
between biology and creativity.
- All science careers involve creativity,
think about it.
We're asking and answering questions,
and we're solving the world's problems.
So the more creatively we can
solve the world's problems,
the more new ideas and
concepts and approaches
we can use to address
the world's problems,
the better off we'll be.
- Creativity is the guiding force
on the path to good science.
So there isn't a science job out there
that doesn't benefit from creativity.
Like you could be an engineer,
building more efficient transistors
for tinier and tinier phones.
You could be a climate scientist
figuring out how we can
reduce our carbon footprint
and save the world from
climate catastrophe,
or an agricultural researcher
deducing efficient ways
to feed the planet,
or maybe, an entomologist like me,
understanding how relationships
between organisms keep us all healthy.
Creativity is important
in all of these careers.
- One really cool job is
working for a science museum.
And so the people who are
like the chief directors
or bioscientists, or what
have you for science museums
usually have a biology or a
science background of some kind,
maybe have gone through even being a PhD
or a post doctoral fellow.
And their job is to design
exhibits for visitors to museums
and come up with engaging ways
to share ideas in science.
And so I just think
that's a really cool job
that you might not immediately think of.
(upbeat music)
- As we move forward,
as scientists, as biologists,
the old adage is true.
A picture is worth a thousand words.
So what is that image, that graph,
that graphic, or even that imagery
that really gets to the core of your idea?
It almost gets to advertising.
You want that image to stick
in your listener's minds.
That both lets them understand
the undeniably complex concept
that you're trying to convey,
but also makes it memorable.
And developing that skill
to come up with that picture
that is truly worth a thousand words
is going to be the skill
that we will all need
going into the future.
- Creativity plays a role in my life
pretty much every single day,
by reminding me not to stop
just because I've reached a setback.
Like hitting a wall as
you're moving towards a goal
doesn't have to be the end for that goal.
To me, it just means
that the path to success
isn't gonna be quite as straightforward
as I originally thought.
Like, the way around
that wall may require me
to climb over it, or tunnel under it,
or maybe even dig straight through it.
But if I'm creative enough,
I can probably find a way
to get to the other side.
And this plays out for me in the lab,
literally every single day.
It fuels tenacity that can see you
through things like graduate school
if you ever choose to go that route.
- I allow my brain to do the work
to get into my creative zone.
When I have a problem to resolve,
sometimes I just sleep on it
and I let my subconscious mind work
through resolving problems,
and solving problems.
Our brains are always at
work like trying defragment
and break apart the
things that we encounter.
So I spend a little time thinking
about how I can approach
things creatively.
And then, I spend a
little time not thinking
about those things and allowing my brain,
and my subconscious mind
to have an opportunity
to do the work for me.
A lot of times when I
come back afterwards,
I've got a great idea.
I've got the answers, and
I have new ways to solve
and resolve things that
I've been thinking about.
- To get into my creative zone,
I do something that I'd like to call
productive procrastination.
I start what I'm working
on way before it's due,
and then in fits and starts,
I work while giving my mind permission
to wander to things that
absolutely are not on the agenda.
It's encouraged some of my
most creative experiences,
some of my best songwriting,
educational videos,
and even scientific breakthroughs
while I was supposed
to be working on something
totally unrelated.
And this won't work for everyone,
but my mind is most creative
when it's free to go on
unplanned adventures.
Good music also helps.
A great playlist, to me, is
worth its weight and gold.
My playlists are special
because they only include
instrumental music
and songs in languages that
I don't actually speak.
So my thoughts don't get too pulled
into the lyrics themselves.
- I've used creative communication
to solve problems related
to especially people
learning different science.
For example, in chemistry,
people sometimes have a hard time
understanding subatomic
particles and molecules and atoms
and making those connections
between quantities and numbers.
So instead of jumping right into that,
which can be very difficult for people,
I've learned to be
creative and use analogies
or relating that to something
that is more accessible,
such as cooking or money
or building something.
And then when people
can make their relation
between something large and familiar
to something small or
subatomic and unfamiliar,
it makes it easier for them
to make those connections
and build upon that knowledge.
- So, several years ago,
I started making videos
of myself explaining biology
and entomology in language
that was accessible and
familiar to people my age
and people who don't fit
the stereotypical model
of a scientist.
It's a choice that I'm really
glad that I made actually.
I've received so much
positive feedback about videos
no more complicated than me holding a bug
in front of a camera, and
actually, just like this.
Me literally holding a
bug in front of a camera
and explaining what makes it tick.
Note to self, I should make a video
about what makes ticks tick.
That'd be pretty cool.
Wait, sorry. That's
neither here nor there.
The point of what I'm saying is the choice
not to excise my personality,
the choice to bring all of my quirkiness
into how I communicate is what
seems to make the difference.
A big part of being creative
really can be just figuring out
how to bring all of you
to whatever it is that you choose to do.
- I think biology is so critical
for everybody to learn
because it defines who we are
as human beings, as animals.
It defines the whole animal kingdom.
And then it goes on to define
the whole plant kingdom,
the insect kingdom.
Understanding those principles
of how living things
are organized is not only a
beautiful thing to understand,
but it gives deep insight
and deep appreciation
for our own lives.
And I think that is the core
of why I find it so important
that everybody study this
beautiful area of academia.
- Biology is super important
to learn for so many reasons.
But the reason that stands
out most to me is, well,
the rarity of life outside
of our little corner
of the universe.
You might not know what I mean,
but stick with me for a sec.
So we are positively surrounded by biology
every day here on Earth,
but we haven't encountered life,
or even evidence of life outside
of this little blue marvel,
even though there is so much
cosmic real estate out there.
Life is really complicated.
And that goes for starting
and sustaining life.
Somehow, ancient organisms
made it work here,
but that doesn't mean that it's easy.
All of us carry on this
legacy of life, finding a way.
But one day, maybe life will
have to find a way through us.
Maybe Earth becomes
inhospitable for some reason,
and we have to figure out
how to live somewhere else.
On that day, success
will depend on how well
we understand the heaps of obstacles
that the stubbornness of
life has already overcome.